thank you very much and good morning
everyone
we have invited here today for what we
hope will be a lively and entertaining
discussion which will not be altogether
off my prompter notes about people who
are not generally spoken to or heard
from in the political process and
particularly this deep into a campaign
young people young voters and perhaps
just as important the generation behind
the current young voters and potential
voters a generation just behind them who
will soon be qualified to vote a lots
been written and said about the fact
that it is a fact that so many young
people who are eligible to vote
potential voters don't vote and a lot of
what's written about and said about
young people in campaigns maligns young
people as quote apathetic and uninformed
unquote MTV and Nickelodeon set out to
get to the root of the issue by talking
directly to young people about the
process about their issues and their
choices if you ask yourself well why are
we here today very simply our goal is to
raise their voices and discuss the
implications of their thinking with the
panel that will join me on stage very
shortly what's going to happen here this
morning we're going to be in three
stages first we're going to look at the
research then we're going to have panel
come up and discuss that and some other
questions and issues about young people
what they're thinking why they don't
vote how they view the campaign those
kinds of things and then we're going to
take your questions from the audience so
the first of those requires me with
pleasure to introduce Betsy Frank the
executive vice president of research and
planning at MTV Networks
Betsy's here to discuss the new research
so let's welcome Betsy Frank I'll see
you in a few minutes
good morning the candidates may be
talking but many of their potential
voters don't seem to be hearing them
while George Bush and Al Gore are
explaining their positions lining up
their supporters and attacking their
opponents to 27 million people they're
speaking another language some of them
have never voted and many of them of
those don't see any compelling reason to
even register much less vote this year
they are the 18 to 24 year olds perhaps
the most disconnected group of potential
voters in the history of the country yet
if you ask them they have strong
opinions on the issues and claim that
they did not leave politics instead they
tell us it's politics and the
politicians who've left them so in a
classic case of the chicken or the egg
the candidates seeing apathy and low
turnout become less and less likely to
speak to the issues of young people
while young adults see that lack of
attention is all the more reason to tune
them out so the cycle perpetuates itself
and what of the generation behind this
one their younger brothers and sisters
right now they're idealistic they're
enthusiastic they're very engaged in the
process sadly though they may well
follow in their older brothers and
sisters footsteps as they grow up and go
through the natural adolescent evolution
from idealistic to realistic and as
you'll hear in a few minutes habits
related to voting both positive and
negative are established early and once
established are hard to break so this
morning we're gonna be talking about two
big disconnects the one between those
idealistic kids and those more cynical
young adults and the one that has
developed over the last eight years to
push young voters out of the political
process what we'd like to do is present
some of the key findings of our polls
and then discuss what it means with as
Dan said our panel of people whose whose
business is to follow politics or to
follow young people first here are the
polls were gonna be discussing full
details including
methodologies number of respondents in
margins of error can be found in the
packets that you'll have the primary
focus though will be the five MTV Time
magazine choose or lose polls which
surveyed seventeen to twenty four year
olds and the four nickelodeon kids
picked the president polls which talked
to kids eight to twelve and adults
eighteen plus before we talk about the
polls themselves
I'd like to step back for a moment and
touch on the few of the general findings
we've discovered as part of our ongoing
research about what's on the minds of
young people today first of all young
people are feeling good about themselves
and their world and let me start with
kids about ninety five percent of kids
say they're happy and according to
Nickelodeon state-of-the-union research
41 percent of six to fourteen year olds
say life is easier for them than it was
for their parents when they were kids
kids teens and young adults as well
describe themselves as smart savvy
self-reliant and they're remarkably
goal-oriented they're also highly moral
and many consider themselves religious
their parents family and friends are
their heroes and role models they're
optimistic about today in the future and
two-thirds of young adults say that they
are satisfied with the direction the
country is going why is this an
important context for our discussion
because while young people know there
are problems in the country their own
lives are pretty good so there's no real
sense of urgency that something has to
change so let's get back to the issue at
hand
despite their self-reliance their
maturity their growing responsibilities
there is one area where that that
traditional rite of passage is not
occurring young adults are not
connecting to the political process now
let me make one thing very clear this is
not a question of apathy 70 percent of
17 to 24 year-olds say they're
interested in issues and causes yet only
30 percent say they're interested in
politics and government and they're
questioning the 2000 election and the
political process in terms of its
relevance to their own lives in July of
1992 for example nearly 57% of 18 to 24
year olds said that they were certain to
vote that November in July of 2000 that
had shrunk to 33 percent well below
voter participation rates for other
demographic groups furthermore the
likelihood of someone registering after
age 20 drops dramatically when we asked
unregistered 18 to 24 year olds
realistically how likely is it that you
will register to vote in the November
2000 election 55% of 18 to 20 year olds
but only 28% of 21 to 24 year olds said
they were certain or very likely to
register in fact among 17 year-olds who
would be eligible to vote in November
the number was even higher than for the
18 to 20 s suggesting greater
hopefulness less cynicism perhaps fewer
distractions
whatever the reason there seems to be a
finite window of opportunity to engage
young people and it looks like that
window is closing so if we know that
young people aren't esse mystic and
they're not apathetic the next logical
question is why aren't they connecting
to the political process well we heard a
lot of reasons for those who were
certain they would not vote they cited a
basic lack of basic information the
belief that acting locally in their own
communities can have more of an impact
than voting the sense that politics is
just about big-money and gross
exaggerations and this is so distasteful
to young people that it distances them
even further from the process the
confidence that the country is already
going in the right direction and the
fact that they don't feel a strong
affinity for either major party and in
fact don't even identify with one or the
other parties but overshadowing any
secondary reasons most of their
complaints stem from a feeling of not
having their interests and concerns
addressed by candidates and not having
the election make any real difference in
their lives
specifically 70% said politicians are
out of touch with the concerns of people
their age
the same percent felt the results of the
election would have no impact on them
personally and on the rare occasion when
politicians actually attend a youth
event and do get the issue right they
tend to talk at rather to their audience
and the message they deliver tends to
have little relevance for them what is
this all mean well it means that
somewhere between 1992 and 2000 there's
been a breakdown in communication a
disconnect if you will between young
people and the politicians who are
supposed to represent their interests
1992 was certainly a bright and shining
moment for young voters there were
economic issues that were critical and
urgent plus a candidate who made them
feel hopeful now the issues have neither
the same level of urgency nor given the
way they're being addressed relevance
and they find the candidates especially
the two major ones uninspiring so young
people don't think politicians are
listening to them and politicians see
low turnout from this group and don't
think that young people care what they
have to say and the result of course is
a widening communications gap but in
fact young people care very deeply about
the issues that affect them personally I
mentioned earlier that the role models
for young people are their parents their
families their friends since they're
focused on things close to home
similarly their biggest worries are
things that affect them directly
when Nickelodeon asked kids and adults
which were the most important issues for
the next president to address the lists
look like this you can see that those
very local personal economic issues of
homelessness and poverty which were
numbers one and three for kids dropped
down to numbers five and six for adults
while war and racism from which kids are
better able to distance themselves rank
much higher for adults and just as kids
and adults have different issues
candidates have very different
priorities from young voters as this
chart clearly demonstrates the
candidates do not have the same touch
points as young people in fact the top
issues addressed by by the candidates
according to CNN
tend to be dominated with by those with
the greatest relevance for senior
citizens Social Security health care
taxes in the economy Medicare Medicaid
defense and campaign finance and while
it's true education is that at the top
of both lists the candidates are
addressing it somewhat differently from
the way they their kids the kids would
like them to address it the candidates
are laying out sweeping plans for
education reform while young people
point to more direct solutions giving
students more individual attention
making the curriculum more relevant to
the real world improving teacher quality
and helping them pay for college without
a burden of debt upon graduation
violence you'll see also dominates the
list of issues for young people
especially domestic abuse and
drug-related violence areas where they
are more likely to be the victims here
two young adults embrace solutions that
get at the root causes of violence like
conflict resolution and reject solutions
that only address its symptoms take gun
control for example in both the
Nickelodeon and the MTV polls kids and
young adults find gun control to be a
clearly-defined issue they are concerned
about the prevalence and easy
accessibility to guns since guns cause
death therefore they favor gun control
and this tends to be true whether they
consider themselves Republicans or
Democrats in other words gun control is
a clear-cut issue among young people far
more so than it is among adults the same
dynamic exists when we ask kids and
adults about bilingual education for
example kids overwhelmingly say the
teachers should teach in the language
students best understand while adults
overwhelmingly say that education should
only be in English how do young people
learn about the candidates
well most young people get their news
from television mostly cable television
and the Internet but consider that oh
sorry
consider that almost half of all adults
under 30 say they use the late-night
talk shows
as a source for campaign news according
to a recent poll from the Pew Research
Center now this carries some pretty
significant implications when you
consider that almost all the jokes on
the late-night talk shows are about the
candidates flaws now of course political
pundits have been around for years but
the culture has become far more extreme
lately resulting in an even further
erosion of the process case in point
people may support bush because they may
question Gore's honesty on the other
side of the coin people may support Gore
because they question Bush's experience
Tim Russert has called it the character
versus capacity balance the late-night
shows continually emphasize character
versus capacity so that very little of
the candidates positive traits come to
light while some information may be
better than none potential voters
especially younger ones are getting bits
and pieces of information that don't
tell the full story young people aren't
getting news and they really aren't even
getting information they're getting
sound bytes and they're getting mostly
negative ones and frankly as of a month
before the election there's been only
minimal penetration with this audience
only about 3/4 of 18 to 24 year-olds
could name both presidential candidates
unaided and somewhere between 1/4 and
30% the vice presidential candidates
suggesting that those sound bites have
not only been negative they've not been
very effective either many of us here
may feel that there's no getting away
from the election and the candidates
these days but amazingly young adults
are managing to do just that so what
does it all mean obviously no one is
suggesting that the candidates ignore
older adults after all there are a lot
of them and the majority of them
actually go to the polls but the
challenge is how a candidate must adapt
the message to different constituencies
first candidates need to understand this
generation just as any good marketer
would just as there are differences
between talking to the MTV audience and
the CNN audience candidates must accept
the fact that this group grew up at a
different time and with different
demands and expectations they're used to
customized personalized messages they're
optimistic but they're also realistic
and pragmatic and want to see solutions
to their problems adjust in concrete
specific relevant local ways and they've
extremely high BS detectors so they're
even less likely than their parents to
forgive or even tolerate double-talk
from candidates secondly candidates
should get more young people involved in
their campaigns however this cannot
simply be a symbolic or token gesture
instead there should be a group of
grassroots on-the-ground representatives
who can talk to young viewers but young
voters listen to their concerns educate
them on the issues represent the
candidates positions and get young
voters excited by the process
25 years ago campaigns would routinely
open offices on college campuses and
hire students as their youth
coordinators and now very little effort
is made third since young people are
turned off by old-time party
affiliations candidates should appeal to
them as independent thinkers not as
politicians tied to big machines and
since young people more than any other
group are turned off by personal or
negative attacks be positive and
optimistic especially when young voters
are in the audience at MTV and
Nickelodeon we believe that if one whole
segment of society is disconnected from
the political process and their voices
are going unheard our representative
democracy is in danger and if our best
possible future leaders don't get
involved in public service or even
grassroots activism and don't run for
office because they've been a Liat
alienated from all but the worst of the
political process that's a pretty grim
prospect as well in fact 60% of young
adults in one of our recent polls said
they would not run for public office
we believe that our role as preeminent
media vehicles for young people is to
inform them listen to them and give them
a voice
MTV's choose or lose is committed to
educating the largest generation of new
voters since the baby boom about the
political process in the presidential
election and registering them to vote
and Nickelodeon's kids pick the
president was conceived to teach and
empower kids across the country via Nick
News special editions and our ongoing
series of polling that you've been
hearing about this morning and now to
discuss the implications can I invite
the panel to join me on stage
you think I got the right chair
well first of all I think you should
give Betsy Frank a great to a round of
applause now let me quickly but not too
quickly introduce the members of the
panel but I'm going to ask for anchorman
indulgence here for one thing that I've
neglected to do something that has been
absolutely essential to my survival in
network television that is introduced my
bosses Andrew Heyward is the president
of CBS News and is here Andrew thank you
for being here Sumner Redstone who as
you noticed the Maharaja of Viacom was
here I'm not sure but thank you both to
be here this morning now as to the panel
Doug Bailey is the president and CEO of
the Freedom Channel he's also
co-director of the rolling cyber debate
where with my old friend Mike McCurry he
oversees the daily online interchange
between the 2000 campaign presidential
candidates he is the founder of youth a
vote that's the first national
registration and online vote in American
history an unofficial underscore
unofficial vote for president Senate
governor and key national issues by all
students in all schools up through high
school Doug Bailey
Kamala Edwards is a political writer at
Time magazine Tamala if you'll raise
your hand so everybody recognizes where
you are on stage it's actually Tamala
thank you
okay use it
Tamela is based here in New York and she
covers politics society and breaking
news she's currently covering vice
president's Al Gore's exciting race with
the presidency earlier this year she
covered former New Jersey Senator Bill
Bradley's exciting campaign for the
Democratic nomination of tamil edwards
channel Thank You Linda Ellerbee is the
host of Nick news Linda here and the
president of lucky duck productions
she's no friend of mine
a Texan and an award-winning television
producer of best-selling author by the
way she has a new set of books coming
out designed for children roughly in the
eleven year age group you can look for
that a breast cancer survivor a mother
and an all-around great person Linda
started at CBS News and then moved on to
another place just about everywhere
she has been at NBC News than at ABC
News and so let's welcome Linnell
betsy frank i introduced her earlier but
she is the executive vice president for
research and planning at mtv networks
she's primarily responsible for a
premier research department but which
provides the company with a solid
understanding of current and prospective
viewers so the audience may be better
served so again betsy front now somebody
named john stewart is the anchor and
co-executive producer of The Daily Show
with Jon Stewart John could not be with
us this morning and so we have the
winner of the John Stewart look-alike
contest who'll be filling in for John
here and on the program The Daily Show
has been John wrote this for me it has
been the torchbearer of Comedy Central's
indecision election coverage such as it
is indecision 2000 has covered the
elections debates and candidates
starting with the Iowa caucus and New
Hampshire primary early this year Jon
Stewart Jon thanks again
and when you get back and see the real
John Stewart telling we're very
disappointed that he had to send this
surrogate for him I loved you well
please don't tell anybody
thank you John Erica Terry is an
integral part of the MTV chooser Luz
street team as a young reporter she's
already been part of several media
frenzies and raves including this past
summers political conventions Erica
Taylor Erica I felt like having blown
Tamara's name that I should do something
to sort Mike McCurry who is generally
acknowledged by Republicans Democrats
and mug wants to him to have been if not
the one of the very best presidential
press secretaries of since that office
came into being Mike is now co-director
of the rolling cyber debate with Doug
Bailey and is one of our old friends and
I want to say something half seriously
at least when we can say that Mike we
appreciate your service to your country
and we're glad you're here this morning
now in hopes that I haven't left anybody
out and if there are no other names that
I can mispronounce or make a mistake
about let's get down to business Linda
Ellerbee
I don't know whether it struck you but
among the findings of the research it
really struck me 25% correct me if I'm
wrong about this of young people could
not name the two candidates for
president me you surprised it then yeah
that's the vice president more the
majority of kids could name the to put
the two presidential candidates and I
think that's good let's get the facts
straight then how many what percentage
could not name the presidential
candidates no one okay understand but um
but again thirty percent could not name
the presidential candidate not the vice
president's credit could not name the
presidential credit did that surprise
you well that's really a question to be
addressed to MTV because that that
applies to their age group our age group
actually did better the younger kids
knew who the candidates were much more
which reflects the the poll findings
that younger kids actually have a
stronger interest in this election than
say a 17 year old why is that ah part of
it I think is is is a wonderful
innocence at that point they still
believe that votes make a difference
that their vote make a difference they
get very angry in fact that they can't
vote when we talk to kids and we say
well what's the biggest change you'd
make it the political system they always
tell us well you know let me vote and
hearing a lot of why I'd almost be
willing to let them they they're very
clear the
they said you know we're we're 20% of
the population but we're 100% of the
future and they really believe that they
can affect and change their world as
they get older and some sort of reality
starts to kick in you get this
distancing that were that we're seeing
in this polling you know although I'd
like to point out that that we have seen
this before after Watergate we saw the
same thing dan remember first election
after Watergate the young voters were
pretty apathetic about voting there was
not a heavy young voter turnout there
was a great deal of cynicism and I think
we're seeing a little of that right now
with the young voter aged people is a
cynicism of particularly when you say
when you look at between 92 and 2000
well I mean that's a pretty specific
time that's one presidency and there's
some symbolism involved there worries
for the younger kids there's less of
that cynicism and they don't look at
whatever scandals or whatever might have
been attached to President Clinton they
think he was a good president but also
it's important to remember to a kid like
that he was not just one present he's
the president he's the only president
they'd ever remember Mike McCrory what
happened between 1992 an election that
seemed comparatively to turn young
people on both those who were potential
voters and younger ones what happened
between then and now to turn them off
well I'd I'm not so sure that 1992 was
many things but I don't think it was an
exceptional time of you know youth
empowerment or interest there was one
thing that did happen Bill Clinton went
on mtv's choose or lose which was a
gamble this is not when he talked about
his underwear by the way it was the
first time during the campaign that he
went on that was a bit of a gamble and
that did open up a new conversation with
these voters I think that's the single
most important thing I want to come back
by the way to at some point have Doug
Bailey talk about the importance of
youth eve oat which is an opportunity
for those kids who could vote to
actually participate in something that
might
them in a pattern of behavior that will
get them interested in campaigns but but
my point would be this the conversations
that the candidates have with this age
bracket adjust as total failure to
communicate they don't speak the
language that these kids can understand
and and we do it all the time this age
bracket think about the graduating high
school class of the year 2000 they were
born in 1982 they don't remember any of
the things Watergate to them might as
well be t-pod don't they don't know what
that is they don't you know they're they
don't have a memory of Ronald Reagan as
president they don't remember the
Challenger blowing up they don't
remember black-and-white television they
don't the kind of the kinds of
references and the ways in which we the
metaphor of politics even the way in
which is covered by the press which is
often filled with sort of sports
metaphors this is not a part of their
language not a way that in which they
could kind of get into the conversation
so it's not because they're cynical it's
not because they're despondent it's
because that they're not hearing
something that they can participate in I
think the the second point I would make
is that there was some tendency Betsy in
your presentation to really say it's the
candidates who are not really speaking
to the issues that kids care about and I
agree with that but that part of the way
in which our culture presents the
picture of the public official and the
presidency is a bit of a mid smash to is
for most of that period in the 80s and
90s if you think about our popular
culture and entertainment the figure of
the public official or even sometimes
the president was either a buffoon
someone to be ridiculed or was as
somebody who is up to some dastardly
conspiracy with black helicopters off in
the desert doing something you know
angry and I think that forms sort of an
idea of what the public official is
about that heads this conversation in
the wrong direction now there are some
hopeful things like the show West Wing
that I think begins to portray more
human side of what people in politics
wrestle with better
don't I think that it's more than just
the conversation Hawaiian campaigns and
politics it's the way the idea of
democracy the idea of the public
official itself that is a little
off-putting to be given Tamala
with the bradley campaign and the gore
campaign do you hear the candidates
those working with the candidates
discussing this disconnect that the
research shows not at all it's not on
their radar screen no at this point
they've realized for this particular
race they're out chasing you know swing
voters in Michigan Wisconsin
Pennsylvania and Florida and they just
don't see young people being part of
that and I want to go back to something
that Mike and Linda were talking about
because I was a college student in 92
and what I do remember is I had been
very political as a younger kid my
parents were very political watched all
the conventions cared about it but when
I went off to Stanford it was a news
Freezone you were so busy with other
things nobody sat down at 6:30 to watch
the news or had a subscription to The
New York Times it was mostly the student
newspaper but what got through to us
about Bill Clinton were two things the
fact that he was a young guy everybody
was Walt talking about the youthful
vigor of this campaign that he was
surrounded by all these young kids the
George Stephanopoulos
of the world and you noticed that it's
like oh this is somebody my dad's age
it's not somebody my granddad's age and
the fact that he did do things like MTV
and that there was a different sort of
patina of coolness about this guy versus
the usual politician I think the culture
dips in and out there times when
politics is glamorous and I think in the
Kennedy years politics was glamorous it
was a cool thing to pay attention and
other times it's not and I think now is
not a cool time if you talk to most
likely to succeed in most high schools
in our hometown of Houston I bet you
most kids would say I want to run an
internet startup or be a venture
capitalist nobody's gonna say what they
used to once a that kid's gonna be
governor one day and so it's a very big
culture change around politics but what
I've seen in actual campaigns and the
primaries in Iowa in New Hampshire where
every vote counts you see lots of kids
and in places like New Hampshire it
really did matter
a lot of those kids came out and it was
the one place that Bradley seemed to
really pick up some votes and beat Al
Gore and the sad thing is if you went to
Nashville right now and walked into the
headquarters for Al Gore you'd see
mostly people my age and much younger
2425 that are regional press secretaries
that are sitting in the war room that
are crunching a lot of the numbers the
main people feeding Al Gore his facts
and figures you know in fact one of his
main policy advisors is a woman named
Sarah Bianchi who was his daughter's
college roommate but I don't think that
that gets through to people that there
are young people affiliated with these
campaigns and I'm gonna be a little
contradictory here and also say that I
put a lot of this plane back on young
people themselves that politicians when
they get down to brass tacks they know
that swing voters you know that they're
gonna pick something oh I'm a black
woman oh I'm a gun owner
oh I fall into some category and they
worry about those groups staying home
but they've got evidence that shows 90%
of black people if they go to the polls
they will vote for the Democrat it's
worth my time it's worth my money to do
an ad buy to spend time with this group
but if you look at young people in fact
they did a story on higher education
only 50% and I know Julia will correct
me if my numbers are on only 50% of
young people we're voting and
politicians look at those numbers and
they know that 75% or more of their
parents vote and therefore you have Al
Gore say you know I will do tax credits
I will do all of these things that help
parents who care about teacher testing
who care about student texting who care
about paying for college on the front
end rather than saying you know what I'm
gonna do things to reduce the amount of
college debt you have coming out on the
other end which is something that is
somebody who's still paying her college
loans is something that would help me
not my parents Doug Bailey on this email
vote or they what region is strongest in
casting the votes or have you broken it
down regionally is it stronger in the
Northeast and say the West what's going
to happen again is it is we have schools
engaged in every state of the country
starting on Monday for 10 days
between October 23rd and November 2nd at
youth Evoque net students registered to
vote through their school's kindergarten
right up through high school
voting in an unofficial vote for
president governor senator and a couple
issues this will be not only the largest
online vote ever by a wide wide margin
we're talking of millions of students
participating in an unofficial vote and
we have intentionally by the way shut
that shut that vote down on November the
second in order to report the results on
November the second in order to
communicate to the campaign's that
there's a big story coming on the night
of November 2nd and they ought to start
talking to those students in any event
it's a it's a fascinating exercise and I
don't think there's one portion of the
country that is stronger than others
it's it's California to New York north
south then let me take advantage of this
audience to ask them a question which
adds one more statistic to one two
something that that we're talking about
how many people here would you raise
your hand if you are a voter everybody
in the room now raise your hand if your
parents voted nearly everybody in the
room I think it's very important to
understand that 50 percent of America's
children live in homes with no voting
parent so the habit of voting most of
you most of us I think voted first
because we knew it was expected of us it
was what our parents did it was the
thing we're supposed to do many children
in this country grow up not knowing that
that's not part of their experience
that's part of what we have to overcome
here arugam in
want you to in as far as you can be a
voice of the street young people history
explain to me give me your opinion about
this disconnect the research clearly
shows a disconnect what it shows to
repeat for emphasis is that young people
are really interested in issues specific
issues particularly those that affect
them but they have very little interest
in the process in the political process
and in government per se why is this
disconnect well I mean I think first off
and look at the nature of the
conversation they've had like I think
that we spent this year choose or lose
in some part trying to focus on that
other 70% the people who are paying
attention and I think that all too often
the conversation in the media and you
know in the political arena when it
comes to young people and while it is
you know a huge number and we do need to
address it focuses so much on the group
of people who are not paying attention
who are not informed or not
participating and ignores the kids out
there who are doing something so I think
that that's first and foremost that we
need to give a little more love to kids
who are involved whether it's on a
grassroots level or in their own
communities or at their schools but what
they are doing that's positive I mean
when the images of young people in the
media and that our politicians in turn
then hold of us are really negative and
ones that I think a lot of young people
feel really powerless to change so I
think that that's first and foremost I
think that part of the reason why
there's a disconnect is in large part
because some of the sources that we're
getting this news from assume that we've
already come to the table with the base
of knowledge that a lot of people don't
have I think a lot of young people need
to be and a lot of Americans in general
need to be re-educated about how the
process does work you know I mean like
everything from you know we assume that
if we put PSAs on TV telling kids to
register the vote that that means they
know where to go to do that and a lot of
people don't a lot of people don't
realize that there are deadlines and
rules and regulations and processes that
need to be followed you know how old do
you have to be to even be elected
president anything like that right there
says already that we've put a you know
some sort of boundary up between you
know who's qualified and who isn't just
because you're a voting age doesn't mean
that you're of an age where we think you
can handle the responsibilities of you
and running for
yourself so I think that there are so
many barriers that set young people up
to be like you are other different you
know just wait a while and we'll you
know to school you a little bit and then
you can come and play with the big boys
so I think that that is you know a large
part of it but I think they're also you
know we need to kind of disagree a
little bit with what Tamela says I think
and people do need to take
responsibility for themselves and making
sure that they are more informed but I
think it's wrong when politicians
cognitive a college campus and you know
talk to us about you know getting more
money for Pino Pell grants and getting
more money for higher education and
improving you know quality of schools
and making our streets safe and all
these things and then show up on the
Sunday morning talk shows and are
strictly talking about Medicare only
giving examples that you know illustrate
what older Americans think are important
and have completely put us out of you
know having any real power or influence
on what the rest of America sees as the
issues that are important to us I think
it's a two-way street in terms of how we
determine what is going to be a central
issue of the campaigns and if the
candidates don't make those things
issues in every single forum things that
they think are important to young voters
then that's gonna reflect we're gonna
realize that I mean I think that the
thing that I took away most from you
know the polling data is that we are the
most media savvy generation you know to
ever have existed in our country and we
realize when we're being suckered and
when we're being snow and I think that
for our politicians to think that that
escapes us is just ridiculous and the
same is true of the mainstream media
Sean you were you sorry I argue I'd like
to actually I'd like to talk
John Stuart there's nothing that I could
possibly say there'll be more
interesting point you mean I've got a
point to me and it is somewhat
antithetical to what I'm hearing but
give me the back your hand if you think
I'm gonna sit here and play the part of
a Jim Lehrer and let you get away in a
moment but I do think that there's some
issues let's take Social Security the
big fight on Social Security now is
really whether or not people ought to be
able to use their own money and invest
in the market for their retirement and
that's really an argument more about
young people than it is around older
people and there are a lot of these when
you look at the polling everybody looks
at education and in some of the things
you pointed out that they want more
specific solutions if I hear Al Gore and
George Bush tell me anything more about
the number of times they're gonna test
teachers test students I mean they're
very specific out there and I think
there's a tax to be paid politicians
know that if you look at the trending
among young people from the time we got
the vote we don't use it and if you
don't use your vote if you don't use
your voice to fault people for not
talking to you I mean I think we've got
to fault politicians but we're not
talking but if you're not showing them
that you have a history you have a
history of you must talk to us there are
other groups gays and lesbians Nora T's
other people that traditionally can feel
shut out but they have shown that they
use their vote and you better pay
attention to them and so the parties
tend to I think young people have to
look at it in that sort of way I'm gonna
make you listen to me because I think
standing there and saying you know why
don't you come talk to me they're not
going to do it but Jon Stewart you've
been very patient thank you
you said you had a point you wanted to
make that's not important
my point is somewhat antithetical to
this whole thing
look my feeling is this the generation
of young voters that we're talking about
have had their asses kissed more than
any generation in the history of
generations that's why we're all sitting
here today it's why MTV exists
culturally they dominate more than not
only should they but more than I think
they can even handle and everything that
we do is geared towards getting their
money and politics is our revenge I
don't want their voice I've heard it can
they get involved of course they can
I've seen him stand outside of this
building for six hours and twenty degree
weather just so they could get a chance
to come upstairs and tell Carson Kid
Rock is awesome so the idea that they
can't get out there and do something
when they want to you've all tried the
who wants to be a VJ thing and literally
a kid will walk from Minnesota to
Chicago
so the idea that they can't get involved
the problem is they are used to being
flattered and having their asses kissed
and having everything changed for them
and their tastes well guess what it's
not that easy when it comes to politics
and as far as a disconnect between
politicians and the language that they
use they're disconnected with everybody
it's not that they don't use words like
fat and what's up when they're talking
about political issues it's that they
are scared to death
that if they say something slightly
askew all of us are gonna dive on them
and show that soundbite three thousand
times on five 24-hour news networks to
the point where they look [ __ ] and
that's what our problem is kids want to
vote vote but I'm sorry you don't
deserve to have camera angles and
politicians talking directly to you it's
your life and if that's not good enough
for you then I'm sorry
you know life isn't Dawson's Creek you
know just because Felicity cuts their
hair doesn't mean the world blows up and
I'm sick I don't like them I'm tired of
them
I'm glad you don't feel strongly about
it I do I and I was I was young Dan
people cared about me did gender sound
I'm saying there is no group gathered in
a room right now trying to figure out
how to get old people to go to the polls
they go annoyingly so we sit here and we
break down the polls of 30% of the kids
in this country don't know who's running
for president make them leave it's eight
letters you have to learn how ridiculous
is that we've gone from JFK to TRL and
it's our fall for kissing their asses
the way we do because they're the demo
that buys deodorant or we think can
change brands and that's it they are
given a ridiculous amount of weight in
this society I'm having problem here's
report there's a disconnect up on the
stage
Erika you have a diametrically opposed
view to what John is just here what do
you say I mean I'm not at all trying to
say that my generation or people younger
than me don't need to be held
accountable to on some level but I don't
think you're right I don't think that
most of the politicians are you know
sucking up to us I just don't think the
culture I recognize that but in the case
of politics they're not and I think that
they do suck up to so many other people
why can't they suck up to us especially
given Cordish every other arena your
your premise is true everyone else does
so why ruin that sense of entitlement
that has been so built into the culture
because whenever it like when Dr Pepper
wants to put some mouth they gotta have
a Benetton with all the different five
different cultures and the doctors
around I'd rather earn something not
based on the fact that you may change
brands and this is not on you by the way
I have this on this is on synergy this
is on mergers this is on everything
that's done that's aimed towards taking
kids from cradle to grave
through a various rotation of brand
products and hooking them on something
in a certain breath and Nickelodeon is a
wonderful channel that's doing wonderful
things but I've got a nephew and if I
find the guy that runs Nickelodeon I
will beat your ass because I am tired of
buying Sponge Bob hats
I said eight-year-old nephew who's got a
Doug t-shirt and a spongebob hat and a
cup of a rug rat and a goddess see the
pokey movie and you know what I told him
you should buy stock in Nickelodeon and
he know what he said to me Viacom's the
parent company actually he's here I
think the person who runs Nickelodeon
Missy Frank remind me a review for us
again you had a percentage of young
people who get most if not all of their
news from late-night comedy programs and
late night program generals about what
it's it's really not most if not all
it's it's some or most and it's just
half of people under 30 say they get
fair to say roughly half but yeah John's
that bother you that worry you you make
a living doing it but absolutely citizen
I wish it was more I wish it was more
because then my salary goes up I'm like
everybody else here's the thing here's
here's again the disconnect between our
conversations everything we're talking
about is how do we get young people
involved to focus on political issues
and things like that I do a show that's
a half hour of political satire a night
not geared towards young people it has
nothing to do with young people it's
about what's funny and smart that's all
we try and do on that show well I should
give a can I make a curse word
yeah I give a [ __ ] about what the young
people want to watch I don't care I just
care about what's funny or what's smart
or what seems to work on this show and
50% of young people then watch it but
the more you gear it towards them it
seems the more you know the whole trend
in TV right now is reality
everybody's gonna be on TV at some point
you're either gonna be an island or in a
little house or on a new show ice floe
where they put you on an ice floe they
push you out and everything's about
reality television yeah look at what the
political television has become it's
more managed and more staged it's like
watching the Emmys from 1977 you know
it's it's the antithesis of where
everything in television is going and
the way to get young people involved in
something is to not care about what they
want just make good things that you feel
strongly about the way politicians can
get people involved is to not focus and
pull and do everything else but to lead
and inspire like JFK you know then then
young people really had a reason not to
get involved John F Kennedy Robert F
Kennedy and Martin Luther King were
killed Vietnam was raging
there was a reason young people could be
cynical about the world to hear young
people go they don't talk my language it
makes you wanna puke hell own that line
let's turn to Mike Mike let me put you
in the position that you you have been
in over the years your candidates in a
tight race he says we have an invitation
to go on Letterman we have a invitation
to go with John on Comedy Central what
do you think what give us an inside view
of how those conversations go and why
the candidates choose to go on some of
the late-night programs with not some
others well the only reason to go on
them is to create
and events not to you know deal with the
reality of taking questions from
Letterman or to try to be funnier than
John it's not to reach the younger
demographic no it's well it has has very
little to do with the demographics of
the audience that your honor has
everything to do with how the event is
covered because most people won't see it
most people are not going to stay up
that late because most people have to
get up and go to work in the morning so
what it's about is creating an event
that then creates an impression that is
you know exactly what happens in the
debates exactly what happens in the way
in which the campaign's communicate with
the target of voter they're trying to
reach and we are at that point in the
campaign right now where it is down to
you know subfractions of electorates and
probably about a dozen states that the
candidates are trying to reach and if
you can create an impression or a
perception by doing that or by doing
something else that's the way in which
the campaign events are structured but I
actually agree with John on one thing I
think reality does count in the end and
I think we are moving in that direction
and that the more telling statistic of
where this generation we're talking
about guest news is that they go online
they go online so much more
proportionally than do the older voters
all that list of what our voters care
about that matches almost identically or
what the candidates talked about as
Betsy presented it matches identically
the most salient issues on the minds of
voters that are age 35 and above that is
the cohort that is less likely to go
online so I one idea instantly is that
campaigns have to make much better use
of the internet and begin to understand
how pervasive that is as a tool of
communicate with exactly the people
we're talking about and Anna said
interestingly Doug and I have been
involved in a project that was funded by
the Marco foundation where we created an
internet platform that's available on
everything from AOL to Yahoo runs all
just about all the major traffic centers
have got access to the content and
there's a lot of interest and a lot of
hits you know a lot of pageviews and
everything but the candidates have not
been using that platform very
effectively to communicate and I
I think that's part of the problem we
got to have this conversation in a place
that people can access it and that and
in a way that's kind of answer the
question that's why candidates do go on
ladder that's why they go on Oprah
because they are trying to say look we
are interested in reaching out and
involving more people in this
conversation
and then we also want that to be covered
and presented as part of the storyline
of what our campaign is about so so
there's a there's an opening here to
kind of recreate the kind of interest
we're talking about one one last point
about John F Kennedy and and I want to
get that I don't want to miss this point
about popular culture plays a role here
too there's a movie coming out here
they're a lot of entertainment folks
here know this a movie about John F
Kennedy and Robert F Kennedy and how
they manage the Cuban Missile Crisis
Kevin Costner's in its coming out I
think in December and I've been helping
the company that's producing it that
that movie is gonna remind this
generation that who we have sitting in
the White House counts an awful lot
because something that they don't know
about the Cuban Missile Crisis when we
almost lost it all really was a story
about how a to very young presidents
mean when you watch this you you're
reminded how young Robert F Kennedy and
John F Kennedy were in and how young
people literally saved the world when we
had a young president back in the 1960s
that will be I think an interesting
moment because we've got a new president
a new Congress having been elected
there's an opportunity coming to kind of
really put a little bit of idealizing
back in politics Lindale but let me ask
you if you a jump you wanted a ask any
politician well we started Nick news
lucky duck Productions produces it and
we started it it will be 10 years this
next this next through how many into
elections this would be this is our
second one yeah but when you run this
straw vote and then call it that among
very young people it's been right on the
money
and I wish that I wanted to comment if I
can get to that by bike you know
associating myself with some remarks
here and something what we've been
talking about is you know when a
candidate decides whether or not to go
on MTV or whether or not to go on John's
show as you say it's about creating an
event in this case this year both of
them chose to go on Nickelodeon we went
around the country and we taped
questions from kids all over the country
and we took them again we did this four
years ago we took them to the candidates
the candidates sit down they watch these
tapes and they answer the questions and
you you ask yourself well know why are
they doing this you know if you ask them
they'll say because we really care about
kids maybe maybe not but what they do
know is that this was the fourth
election that Nickelodeon has run kids
picked the president and in the three
previous elections and what we do by the
way is what we aired that show and now
we open the polls tomorrow there's an
800 number which I've managed to
misplace but Dan can get it for you or
anybody from Nickelodeon we open the
polls tomorrow we open the phone lines
and kids vote and they vote on the
Internet and Sunday night at 8:30 on
Nick news we tell you who kids elected
these candidates are very well aware
that for the last three elections kids
have picked who the rest of us have
picked but they've done it a couple of
weeks before the election so if you ask
me why they're sitting down to listen to
kids presidents I'm gonna give them the
benefit of the doubt let kids questions
I won't give them the benefit of the
doubt and say they are interested in
kids but I'm also gonna say they have
recognized this for a bellwether poll
and that they are very interested to see
how they do it and for Nickelodeon here
is the number by the way thank you very
much' nation the number to vote this is
the number to vote one eight hundred
seven onine for one hundred and that's
between four and 6:30 p.m. tomorrow on
Friday
vote early and often
Linda questions how do we know that
those who's both are actually young
people not their parents or you don't ya
can this be manipulated by the campaign
it can be manipulated on the Internet
then on the phones for some reason or
another it is a lot easier to sit at
that computer and hit the button you
know 500 times that it is to gather 500
people to agree that lately in the sense
that Linda is talking about it I
absolutely disagree in relation to the
youth Evoque which is a registered vote
through the school's one student one
vote every student has a registration
ended a unique registration number once
that number has been used they can't use
it again we don't have a phone number
you a vote net is where is where you
find it and if you want a school to
participate that's how you good yeah
thank you John
you feed boat dotnet that's what we're
going to do now how what each one of us
works on happens to be the most
effective way of choosing the president
I'm shocked and surprised I shocked
amazed myself and amazed we're gonna
open it up to questions from the floor
now the way this work there are
microphones and please go to a
microphone so everyone in the room can
like a sort of a Town Hall format in
some respects Oh in some respect except
we are not standing up as were your two
favorite calves we president would run
well I was a little fearful you didn't
bait myspace John so we segue down I
wouldn't going the other way so we take
questions from the audience now yes sir
please identify yourself
Matt sites from The star-ledger I had a
question for Linda Ellerbee you said
that younger kids that seem to have a
stronger interest in the selection
process that the seventeen-year-old
might this possibly be because seventeen
year olds talked to and listened to
their parents a lot less than young kids
do well it might be and we're always
aware that the Nickelodeon vote and the
kids picked very often I think does
reflect kids
voting the way their parents are going
are going to vote that's what in effect
makes
the bellwether a bellwether poll and I
think it's you know I also think that's
a natural kind of thing I mean part of
the growing process is rebellion and if
you've got a 17 year old that is sitting
down every night and going daddy mommy
tell me what to think you got something
wrong with that 17 year old however
having said that I must tell you the
number of Nick news programs and
specials we've produced where we I'm
sitting on the floor with a bunch of you
know 10 and 12 year olds and the parents
are off in the green room because I
don't want them to have to look at their
parents when they're answering questions
and there's there's the jaw drop moment
always there's when a child up opens kid
opens the mouth and it starts to answer
a question and the parent is in the
green room going where did he get that
that's not what I think so you know we
try on Nick news to give them the
stories each week about the issues ways
that they can start to make up their own
mind how much do they I don't know and
if I could have follow-up question well
for mr. McCurry you mentioned in the
beginning of this discussion that for
the generation of voters out there
potential voters Watergate is like the
Teapot Dome scandal and people really
have no memory of say Ronald Reagan to
what degree should politicians take this
into account and if in fact they do take
it into account as a way to more
effectively reach young voters is that
perhaps a bad idea a bad thing well it
just doesn't reflect a failure of the
educational system rather than a
politicians to speak the right language
no my point was that the metaphor and
the vernacular of politics often kind of
assumes a common experience for voters
that talks way above the head and they
the memory and the collective experience
of exactly this age group and what
happens is I think politicians very
often react by trying to be hip or cool
and figure out you know references that
they think the audience will get rather
than maybe if it's finding some other
way to kind of in
and bring them into the conversation I
don't fault necessarily the schools I
think they would go back a second one of
the reasons may be why Linda's age group
is a little more tuned into this is that
they spend time in elementary classrooms
with teachers who are looking for units
to teach about the campaign whereas when
they get to high school they're going
off they may take a you know an American
civics course or something but they
probably don't have a curriculum that
really reaches them so I think part of
this is just how we bring it into the
schools and talk about it but but I
don't you know it's my point really more
is the politicians need to think about
if they want to reach this group really
think about ways in which they can have
a more embracing or if you know a way of
presenting their platform that really
will kids will get because that's not
that's that's the disconnect right now
we take another question let me
encourage you if you have questions
about the research itself Betsey Frank
has it I I'm not sure disabled and have
a copy of the Betsy if not they will do
some summary information and everyone
can call me if they have someone
specific go back to the question but
don't hesitate to ask Betsy about the
about the polls and the research itself
if you care to yes sir oh sure hi I'm
Russell Cowan from Scholastic this
question is really for anybody I'm
wondering what the impact of online
polling actual I don't mean polling I
mean voting will have on the future will
get more teams and maybe 20s and
20-somethings involved in the voting
process I know they've already tried
this on a municipal level I think in
ever you like to take a swipe down well
the whole goal of the youth vote frankly
is to turn today's students into
tomorrow's voters I there is some
research done by the National
Association secretaries of state I
that's an organization that is very
concerned about the low voting among 18
to 24 years old that I
new voters sometimes don't show up to
vote simply because they don't know
quite what is expected they don't know
what the voting apparatus is they don't
know what they're supposed to do when
they go behind the booth behind the
curtains they don't want to be
embarrassed it's also related to the
point that I think Mike was making a
moment ago there is less civics taught
in the schools every year there is
acidic sizz not part of standardized
testing and therefore it gets a little
bit less attention to feature so what
what we're trying to do frankly is to
get into the schools and and facilitate
the teaching of more civics and at the
same time get youngsters familiar with
the voting process and the thinking
process that goes through that they go
through in if to the degree that they
are voting when they're 12 and 15 and 17
hopefully they'll be real voting real
voters when they're 18 but I have one
plug that I want to get in here just for
a moment MTV has been kind enough for
those of you I don't want to spend more
time on youth evoke but it's probably
new to most of you if you have an
interest in finding out more we're doing
a little briefing on the on the 45th
floor in the West conference room at 11
o'clock
that's the Frank question have you run
any polling do you have any research or
you nobody has that indicates the
percentage of young people who
understand that a presidential election
is decided by electoral votes rather
than a national vote I believe is Matt
here was that part of the last poll the
the one we did in conjunction with
that's good since most grown-up stuff
we don't know we don't ask about the
electoral college exactly but we do ask
whether or not they can no they don't
ask about the electoral college you
stand on the church okay we get back the
question for the audience you just in my
experience and this has really been
driven home to be during this campaign
the number of adults who don't
understand about electoral votes and
when you happen to mention in some copy
read on the air that our polling for
electoral college votes shows Gore with
so many and Bush's winning we get
telephone calls and people who say what
is this electoral book these are both of
your ducks so that led me to the
question about how many young people
perhaps somebody we can do that question
who take another question from floor now
yes ma'am
hi it's a Judy McGrath from MTV and I
want to tell John where are switching
out for the History Channel right after
this full time it's a good thing okay I
have a question for you actually
what's bono like
at least you didn't say bono am i new
there are a lot of things I could say
listening to all of you this morning
could because this really is important
and interesting stuff to the electoral
college point you know we have aside
from being the pop cultural people we
try to do social issues cultural things
year round in a variety of ways and we
have constantly done pieces about here's
what the Electoral College is to a
soundtrack by Kid Rock maybe but to try
to sort of put some of that more serious
and important stuff out there and I
actually have seen some of the people in
our polls say well I think it's safe to
vote for Nader because I think in my
state doesn't matter the Electoral
College is going for one of the other
candidates I think what is true though a
theme for young adults whether they're
more interested in this election or less
it is a time of idealism and inspiration
to your their job is to lead and inspire
and I mean I think all if all people
look for that young adults look for that
more than anyone and whether or not they
hear I agree with Erika that I don't
think I think you hear a different
message when you go to like the forum we
did with Al Gore and he Ann Arbor than
what you hear I'll talk about when he's
on national television in a debate he
doesn't sort of keep the connection
flowing but I do think that you know our
job in the media certainly in a young
adult media like ours is to keep this as
part of the dialogue all the time every
day you're in and year out and we do try
to do that to your point I also believe
that we have seen time and again that
the habit of voting in the culture the
sort of the world I grew up in you know
where the everybody in the neighborhood
worked on the corner and everybody voted
it is kind of absent from you know
America's dinner conversation if you
will and that does play a role I mean in
our polls and you can take away from
this whatever you would like the number
one person that even young adults say
they admire her parents number two was
back but an individual thinker I might
add
a desire to see even if Ralph Nader only
gets four six percent of the vote and
nothing like Ross Perot a desire for
legitimacy for a third-party candidate
or more of that sort of thing these are
real issues and I don't think they get
talked about outside of you know what
you see on a television screen are on
your PC it isn't part of the dialogue of
American life full-time so you're left
with movies and you're left with you
know two sound bites and you're left
with MTV and I think it doesn't all come
together as a part of your daily life
that's the end of what your question to
D History Channel comment coming no
question I think there's a question in
the back where Simmons sorry India
yes Andrew Andrew Heyward from CBS News
I was very struck with what Tamil is
said about the news free zone at
Stanford you know as recently as 1992
and so that's been the experience of my
kids in college even more recently
that's a big contrast to 20 years before
that when I was graduating when Vietnam
what was going on as John said and civil
rights movement was raging so we have to
remember that adults also are
increasingly disengaged from political
process it's not just a youth problem
and so I guess the question becomes I
don't really necessarily believe this
but I'd like to provocatively ask it to
what extent is apathy good is happily a
reflection of a contentment Betsy's poll
shows it things are basically okay in
the country we have a democracy in which
people know they can vote they're
certainly aware that they have the right
I think every kid would know that and
yet they choose not to as do most adults
sadly so the question is why is it
important for us to engage in this much
after why is choose or lose important
what's the lose part of choose or lose I
realize address that to anybody on my
end the one thing in some of this is
anecdotal that I've heard from young
people as we've been traveling all over
the country this year is that regardless
whether or not they're conservative or
liberal they feel as though they're not
being listened to they feel as though
they're not being heard and they kind of
go back to Tamara's point then the only
sort of recourse that you have to even
begin to get to the point where you're
talking about substantive issues you're
talking about things that young people
actually care about is for them to be on
the map and the only way to do that is
by getting out there and voting I mean I
think initially I think that that's a
hundred percent right that you know we
mean in 92 we turned out in huge numbers
and I think it made a difference for how
we were spoken to and how we were
included in 96 and I think that the same
will be true in 2000 if we don't show up
and you know it is the you know that
same issue is going to come up again of
well you guys shot yourselves in the
foot you know that's why you don't get
spoken to that's why no one's and you
know engaging you so I think that that I
mean if or as much as I don't believe
that young people are this monolith that
we're going to be able to you know as
any other group is to be able to be
represented in some huge number um you
know and one fell swoop I guess is what
I'm trying to say I do think though that
in order for us to even get to the point
where we're be we're seen in the same
nuanced ways that you know the 45 year
old population is seen is for us to get
out there and turn out and vote and
become a demographic that then has to be
paid attention to and has to be given
the same respect that other groups are
given to really see that you know what
there's as much difference in as much
variety and what we think and what we
believe in what direction we want to see
the country go in as there isn't any
other segment of the population and I
think for right now that's ignored by
both the media and our politicians
because we're not out there in any kind
of meaningful way thank you let me ask
you a question if I may
keeping in mind that what the research
shows of the percentage of young people
who get their news get a lot of the news
from late night comedy and late night
programs in general can you or can you
not foresee a time when somebody's news
division for a large news operation with
the cable or over-the-air
would say look we're not gonna we're not
gonna cede that ground to entertainment
that maybe we should put a news product
on the air you calling me out is this a
are you saying you want to go
head-to-head uptake 145 pounds of asthma
I'll take you remember trust me you'd be
over contract I know can you foresee a
time when that would happen or what
would it be is it likely to always be
considered quote too hot for anybody's
news division to put this kind of
program the kind of program that John
does under under the auspices of a news
division well I think there ought to be
more provocative programming under news
division auspices I do think it's
unfortunate to use the buzzword
affiliate there's a disconnect between
the notion of news and the notion of
strongly-held edgy commentary and
reporting so I agree with that but I do
think even though there have been
experiments and Linda's is the most it's
more than an experiment it's a big
success while there have been programs
geared to kids it's a niche excuse me
and mainstream news is not going to be
geared to young people as long as they
don't watch it and there is a
chicken-and-egg quality to that but the
fact is that every attempt to engage
young people directly by major networks
has failed I think there's a reason that
Linda's program airs on you know hugely
established brand that is obviously a
favored in a certain demographic group
and the same goes for choose or lose I
think if you tried those programs on a
mainstream network they would fail
miserably and commemorate the commercial
terms of working backwards because it's
you know when I watch i watch the news
division though I think it's primetime
live or 20/20 and then they do 20/20
downtown you know for the kids and it's
the same like you've done in Midtown but
did you visit and it's just it's the
same lady but she has to stand outside
with a leather jacket all right
Johnny do you think like yeah man I got
news for you I guarantee that now
guarantee that they're defining kids as
something like 41 as opposed to 15 I'm
saying it's working backwards and it's
not a question of the host being too old
or too young or the material being
having a driving soundtrack it's it's
putting out a product that they come to
not backing into it in a reverse
mechanical way of the young folk like it
fast and quick and they like it edgy and
outside and they like it in leather and
not in wool you know Ralph Nader
couldn't be corn here you know what I
mean what's corn here then the guy who
invented the safety belt you know and
yet kids block to him because he's not
about crack and they know when you're
backing into it and I think that the
worst thing that we can do is to gather
and figure out how we can get the kids
involved I think the best thing we can
do is to go out and stop stop what what
Mike talked about which is figuring out
ways that we can get our message to this
audience get your message to what you
believe and the audience that that
appeals to will follow
well not rather somewhat at least
inspirational is did you have something
I don't your fight to Andrews question
about the danger of apathy because I did
find out to be a really interesting
question and unfortunately I think
people don't often realize that no the
next day on November 8th they won't wake
up and the world is drastically changed
because it's Al Gore George Bush but
it's the longer term things when they've
got to put people on the Supreme Court
and those sort of things that could
change personal freedom which it's
interesting the kids say Beck is number
two after their parents somebody who
they think of as an independent free
thinker and when you think of the courts
most of those decisions impact you know
choice or not illegal drug search or not
Miranda rights or not and I wonder if
that was put out there to people that
you could wake up and in two years your
life would be very different
they realize that apathy is not a really
good thing we're somewhat over time
which leads me to say that might
mercurial have the last word a one quick
point about how we measure activism
we've talked a lot about voting as being
whether or not that's the salient way in
which you define participation one thing
that's encouraging about the research is
that there is a high degree of idealism
great interest in issues that matter and
participation in community related
things that that count this is a very
active generation when it comes to doing
things that I call politics which is
getting out getting involved in
community shelter programs and recycling
efforts or whatever the cause is and
this is a participatory group I think
the challenge for electoral politics and
campaigns is to connect to that activism
and make it all part of what we think of
as citizenship thank you all for coming
this morning is a coda this
I call your attention to the research
that Betsey Frank and her group have put
together so effectively the core part of
it to me is that the research indicates
that young people are interested in
issues and causes but they are not
interested in politics per se for that
matter government per se the majority of
young people said let me remind you that
politicians are out of touch with their
concerns and that the election will have
no impact on them personally we can
argue about whether they should have
those views or not but it's very clear
that they those are their views thank
you again for coming this morning don't
forget to vote